what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another Game of Thrones Season
7 trailer breakdown video the Game of
Thrones community is electric right now
after the second trailer for the seventh
season has dropped and I must say this
new trailer is absolutely incredible
there's so much more taken place in this
one so let's get right into this I will
be referencing spoilers in this video so
proceed with caution because I will not
be holding back anything this time the
trailer opens up with the scene of songs
out and the godswood of Winterfell she
is walking away from the weirwood tree
and as this is happening we can hear a
line of dialogue from little finger
Littlefinger says don't fight the north
or the south fight every battle
everywhere always in your mind once
again we aren't exactly sure who he is
saying this - this could be Littlefinger
and Jon having a conversation down in
the crypts or this could be songs and
Littlefinger having a conversation after
John leaves 105 but whatever it is
Littlefinger is up to no good once again
and this will be the last season we see
Littlefinger and Sansa will play a big
role in his inevitable death next we see
the gate opening up at the wall and it
quickly cuts to two people on the other
side of this gate you can clearly see
that this is brain and Meera gaining
access through the wall and most likely
a Castle black but the way they edited
this I think they want us to think that
this is the same gate branimir or coming
through but I still think this gate with
the spikes on it at the bottom will be
the gate at eastwatch-by-the-sea because
the gate at Castle black does not have
spikes on the bottom of it like the one
we see in this trailer but either way
it's very exciting to finally see
Brandon the trailer and boy oh boy did
they deliver with some brand scenes this
time but we're going to get into those
in a minute we then cut to another scene
north of the wall but this time it's Jon
Snow and his companions and this is most
likely going to be the mission they go
on to capture a wight in order to get
itself to prove to all the other Lords
of Westeros that the threat beyond the
wall is real next we cut to a scene in
King's Landing where we see a mob of
people cheering as some men of the city
watch escort someone through this crowd
and I think this is one year on Greyjoy
arrives in King's Landing to meet with
Cersei Lannister to discuss terms of
making an alliance with each other they
both need allies right now and they both
have a psychotic personnel
so this should be a very interesting
relationship between these two
characters in speaking of Cersei
Lannister we see her next in the trailer
and it appears that she is in a very
dark looking room most likely some sort
of dungeon or sell at King's Landing I
think this is going to be where Cersei
keeps her new prisoners Euron will be
arriving in King's Landing with three
prisoners which he will give to Cersei
as a gift after your own attacks
Daenerys is fleet he's going to take
yara gloria and tyene santa's prisoner
and once Cersei and the mountain get
their hands on them this is not going to
end well and by the looks of this room
it appears that it's going to end badly
for these ladies next season next we see
Daenerys in her war room at Dragonstone
running her fingers across the table map
of Westeros most likely thinking about
her next move or attack in Westeros the
scene quickly cuts to a small boat
arriving on the beach and this will most
likely be fian arriving at Dragonstone
after he narrowly escaped a vicious
attack at sea led by euron greyjoy
unfortunately for Theon he was not able
to save his sister but hopefully him and
Daenerys devise a plan to get her back
we then see Arya arriving somewhere on a
horse and we have seen a photo from this
scene months ago and in my opinion I
think this may be Arya arriving at
Winterfell and she's looking at her home
for the first time in a very long time
and it's going to be very exciting
having Arya Stark back in Winterfell
next season with her family next we see
Jaime Lannister walking around a castle
and if you look closely you can see a
dead body laying there on the ground
this will most likely be at Highgarden
after Jamie and his Lannister forces
take over the castle next season Jaime
and Bronn will March the troops down to
Highgarden and storm the castle most
likely it's going to result in lady
Alana's death we've seen photos from
this set for months now and you can
clearly see the Lannister flag flying
high above the castle now and once again
we see creepy-ass Littlefinger sneaking
in spying around Winterfell and I think
this may be a little finger spying on
Jon Snow while he is down in the crypts
paying his respects to his family
right before he leaves to head south in
the last trailer we saw a confrontation
between Littlefinger and Jon down in the
crypts and seeing him sneaking around
like this must be why he's going to say
something out of line could Jon that
causes him to cry
and by the throat and slam him against
the wall and I can't wait to see this
slimy little prick get what's coming to
him next we see Daenerys Targaryen
walking along the beach of Dragonstone
and while she is walking we can hear Jon
Snow and he says for centuries our
families fought together against their
common enemy despite their differences
we need to do the same if we're going to
survive because the enemy is real and
it's interesting to hear John say this
as we see Daenerys because we all know
that the Starks and the Targaryen had
beef because of lianna but now we can
expect to see a stark and Targaryen
alliance to fight the real enemy the
White Walkers which is what Jon Snow is
talking about this will probably be John
talking to everyone at Winterfell when
he has all the other Lords together in
the hole which we've seen photos from
this scene as well John will need to
rally everyone together in order to
stand a chance against what's coming as
John is talking we also see the narrow
strip down Stannis's old banner that was
hanging in Dragonstone Daenerys
Targaryen has arrived ladies and
gentlemen and her dragons are getting
very excited we can see them flying
around the island and the next shot
making themselves right at home and I
can't wait to see the look on Circe's
face when she sees just how big these
dragons are there should be a lot of fun
we then see another shot of Theon
Greyjoy and it's my time in this scene
as well and you can see hot embers
flying around as this massive naval
attack has taken place
Euron Greyjoy will strike Daenerys is
fleet and he's going to take out you're
a great joy sleet and the sand snakes
Martell flee this is when urine will be
taking some prisoners with him to King's
Landing next we see gray worm on a boat
and he does look badass he kind of
reminds me of shredder from the Ninja
Turtles and I think this is a casually
rock or Lannisport
I think grey worm is looking for an
access point to gain entry into the
Lannister Castle in order to take it
over it looks like he may have found a
secret passageway to get inside the
castle without anyone knowing they are
even there the Lannisters ancestral home
is about to get ran right through by the
unsullied
we then see Brienne and Podrick arrive
at Winterfell then we see the Hound up
north in the snow and it looks like he's
in a fight The Hound will be with Jon
Snow and several other big characters on
this mission north of the wall
we're going to see more scenes from this
later then we get two quick cuts of this
massive battle that's taking place next
season which has been dubbed the field
of fire 2.0 the Lannister forces will be
met head-on in the open field against
the Dothraki in at least one of the
narrow seas dragons this is going to be
an absolute bloodbath which will [ __ ]
the Lannister army we get another quick
cut of the battle taking place on the
sea and in this scene you can see Yara
trying to make an escape as you're on
and his crew rate for her fleet we are
finally going to see your on Greyjoy
used properly and by the looks of a few
clips we've seen from this battle I
don't think it's going to disappoint
you're a Greyjoy can practice her
parkour all she wants but it's not going
to be enough to escape the wrath of
Euron Greyjoy
now this next scene looks absolutely
incredible bran stark is finally
harnessing his powers and it's going to
be amazing to see this put to the screen
you can see dozens of crows flying above
what looks like the night Kings Army in
my opinion I think those are thousands
of whites right down below those crows
and this is definitely taking place up
north bran might even be watching Jon
Snow and his companions get attacked
during this white capture mission or
this could also just be another vision
of his but I'm going to make a separate
video about this scene so I don't want
to get into too many details right now
but we also see the night king snap his
head up and look at something and this
could be him looking at all the crows
flying above or this could also be when
Daenerys shows up on her dragon but
whatever it is it definitely has the
night Kings full attention because when
Jon Snow goes north to capture this
white him and his team are going to get
surrounded by the white army and if all
the leaks are true then that means the
nurse and her dragons are going to show
up so this could be the night king
seeing Daenerys and her dragons this is
going to be [ __ ] insane my height
level is through the roof right now
seeing the night king and his army in
the same scene with the dragons is going
to be awesome I'm very excited for the
season now we also see brain in a
wheelchair out at the weirwood tree and
it appears that there is a new maester
there now it's hard to say exactly what
bran is going to be seeing out here as
of right now the possibilities are
endless he may be watching Jon get
attacked more to the wall but whatever
it is it's going to be something epic
this does look like the same we're way
free at Winterfell so hopefully bran
does make it safely back home so we can
get there stark reunion that we've all
been waiting for next we see beric
Dondarrion looking like an absolute
badass north of the wall and once again
berrak ignites his sword into a flame as
he is about to fight the night king's
army and i don't know about you guys but
I can't wait to see this mission next
season this is going to be insane I've
told you in my death predictions video
that I think beric Dondarrion will die
on this mission but hopefully he's able
to kick some serious ass beforehand I'm
a big fan of beric so I'm going to hate
to see him go but I think in order to
raise the stakes they're going to most
likely kill off some characters during
this attack now we see you're on and his
new gradually fleet arriving at King's
Landing and like I've said many times
before Euron's going to arrive in King's
Landing with his prisoners and he's
going to greet with Cersei and Jaime to
forge a new alliance this should make
for a very toxic relationship but I'm
really looking forward to it
we then see Daenerys one more time on
Dragonstone overlooking the water and
she turns her head to look at someone I
think this is going to be the scene with
her and Jon Snow Jon Snow's going to
tell Daenerys how important it is for
her to help him fight the others he's
going to need to express the urgency of
the situation at hand and this next
scene looks cool as hell Jaime Lannister
is charging on his horse at full speed
across a battlefield that is on fire
with bodies scattered everywhere
the Lannisters will lose this battle but
not without Jaime putting up one hell of
a fight and it is nice to see him in
some action finally but we then go back
to the north where torment is kicking
some white Walker ass this mission north
of the wall will end up being one of the
greatest scenes of all time whether you
like the reasoning behind this or not
this will be an incredible thing to
watch all these main characters together
fighting the night king and his army
what's not to like
buckle your seat belt my friends but
then the scene cuts back to the field of
fire while the dragon is flying and
right above the Dothraki Army charging
full speed ahead we are finally going to
see the Dothraki army fight in the open
field something Robert Baratheon was
very afraid of this is going to be a
bloodbath we then go back to the battle
I see with the scene of Theon and Yara
looking up at the sky as it lights up
this is going to be when you're on a
text or flee and
you already know how this is going to
end Yara and Theon are about to take a
big L right here next we see Jon Snow
and his men standing on a cliff as
thousands of whites climb up it and
surround them you can see beric
Dondarrion flaming sword right behind
Jon as Jon watches the swarm of whites
quickly approach him this is going to
get very tense very quick and once again
we get another quick love scene between
missandei and grey worm and they're
going to make us like this relationship
then grey worms probably going to end up
being killed just to make this more
emotional because they're going to have
us thinking there is true love for once
but we know how this is going to end -
one of them will die now this next clip
has me very excited and it's hard to see
this man's face with the sunlight behind
him but that is the Hound ladies and
gentlemen and if you look behind him you
can see that he is standing in the
dragon pit and guess who else is going
to be at this dragon pit the
[ __ ] mountain cleganebowl is
back on the table
this is where Jon Snow is going to bring
the captured white to show to everyone
that the threat is real and this scene
that the dragon pit was reported to have
upwards of 20 main characters and I told
you all months ago if the mountain and
the hound are here at the same time
there is no way they don't confront each
other I'm not saying we're going to get
Clegane both for sure but it's still
very possible and we get another amazing
theme with what appears to be Jon Snow
going toe-to-toe with another white
Walker it looks like this man does have
a man bun so I think it's Jon Snow and
he's about to kick this white walkers
ass and I'm telling you this scene north
of the wall is going to knock your socks
off I'm so excited to see this go down I
hope they kill several white walkers I
hope we see ice spiders polar bears
dragons and the whole nine [ __ ] it let's
go balls to the wall next is feeln
arriving at Dragonstone after his uncle
Euron just kicked his ass out at sea we
see you're on great joy in the next clip
and he's finally reaching his potential
and showing us just how crazy he
actually is this is going to be so much
fun
I think season 7 is going to be
action-packed from the start to the
finish this could end up being the
greatest season ever I mean who knows
but I know I'm excited as hell after
watching this trailer I hope we get to
see the euron greyjoy that we saw in the
Forsaken chapter if we can get even just
a piece of him it's going to be awesome
we
then see Daenerys on her dragon and it
looks huge and that does appear to be
Dragonstone because you can look at the
castle behind her and it does have the
same shape of that castle so I'm not too
sure what she could be doing on
Dragonstone with her dragon right here
she does look to be intimidating someone
with her dragon and it does look
terrifying 401 is massive disease and I
feel bad for whoever has to fight
against Daenerys this season and this
next part is pretty interesting we then
get a line of dialogue from Sansa and
she says when their snow falls and the
white winds blow the lone wolf dies but
the pack survives she could be saying
this to Aria when Aria shows up in
Winterfell but she could also be saying
this to Littlefinger right as her and
Arya are about to kill his ass
Zhaan's is about to get much darker this
season she's put up with enough [ __ ]
from Littlefinger and that would be a
great thing to say to him as her in
Oriya or standing over him about the cut
his ass down but if Sean's there saying
this we can see someone up north riding
off on a horse and we also see Jon Snow
cut down one more white before he is
fully surrounded by them I think this is
going to be when Uncle Benjen shows up
to save Jon and I think this is John
riding off on benjin's horse after he
saves him from being surrounded by the
whites the horse that this person is
riding off on is black just like
benjin's and this is obviously way up
north just by the looks of all the snow
on the ground but it's going to be sad
as hell people I'm telling you
Jon's finally going to see his Uncle
Benjen again and after all these years
of wondering what happened to him
after he left to go ranging beyond the
wall and it's going to suck to see
benjin die especially if Jon has to
witness this as he rides off to safety
but it wouldn't be Game of Thrones
without seems like that this trailer was
absolutely crazy and definitely more
exciting and action-packed than the
first one there are so much to analyze
here which I'm going to make more videos
soon and I'm going to dig deeper into a
few of these scenes so comment below and
tell me what you think how excited are
you now I know my height level is
through the roof let me know your
thoughts on everything I want to see
what all of you have to say about this
epic trailer thanks for stopping by and
watching the video I appreciate all of
you that show up to support me in the
videos especially everyone on patreon I
love all of you and I'll see you down
below
by